news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
uh let's see let's go next to
let's go to our caller from the 774
who i have noted as a woman from
massachusetts or
rhode island does that make sense 774 do
you know who that is
uh yeah is it me that is exactly what
was your name for some reason we didn't
get it last time
uh jen jen okay what's on your mind jen
yeah
i was living on the the border so i
still have a mass number but
i'm actually in providence now okay
that's allowed um
now jen you're coming in so hot please
try to keep the phone just a little
further from your mouth and you'll be
able to
hear you much more perfectly all right
is this better oh my god that's so much
better thank you
okay thanks uh so do you know anyone who
worked um for the census this year as an
enumerator or anything
not personally but i've had them come to
my house
okay so i did i was an enumerator for
three weeks
and uh there might be some calls for
concern coming up in the next 10 years
with the results yeah this was a
complete mess
yes uh i did it 10 years ago and of
course it was a much you know different
political climate than what it is now
right but this was horrible they tried a
completely new system they tried doing
it all by smartphone
and it was constantly giving us errors
it would just drop
us from time to time it would send us to
completely wrong neighborhoods
uh and there were just a lot of people
who did not want to be counted or people
who you would answer the door and they
would be crying finding out a family
member just got covered
oh my god you were coming face to face
with the virus and like oh crap did they
have it did they breathe on me
you know things like that now let me ask
you this jen jen let me ask you this
when someone didn't want to be counted
what was their explanation why why would
what did they say a lot of times they
would lie and claim they did it online
or send it to their mail the mail i can
understand with what's going on
but if they did it online it would have
been coming up a few people
did get flat out aggressive and said
they don't want trump knowing their
business
um that they don't think we need to know
also wow providence is a very uh
epically diverse area
a lot of hispanic uh residents and they
thought that that
uh citizenship question would probably
be on there right
right right right so they were terrified
that we were going to start asking them
about that and they didn't know that did
that didn't pass
so a lot that's interesting we're not
even answering the door
that's interesting because i previously
said once the citizenship
question was thrown out that the damage
may well have been done
merely by proposing it and that it may
not even get to people
that it was thrown out and it sounds
like you're saying that's exactly what
happened
yes we definitely had the repercussions
of that as soon as they talked about it
i just thought oh man i wanted to do it
this year it's going to be a myth
and it was even worse than what we
expected do you think that you received
uh adequate training for doing this
during a pandemic or were you just kind
of thrown to the wolves
we were pretty much thrown at the wolves
because they couldn't really do any
in-person training they had a few online
videos they had us watch
wow um but for the most part the phone
system would kind of walk you through it
but when it was constantly just kind of
tripping over itself
it was just causing more and more
problems and
at one point they just started dropping
people because we had too many like do
not answers and things like that where
they're like yeah
your assigned neighborhoods have gone
stale we have no more need for
you goodbye well i wish i could say
190 i i wish i could say what you were
telling me was surprising
but we've been talking about this for
the last four years that this is exactly
how the census was going to go
and jen it sounds like it's going
exactly that poorly
yeah so there's going to be some bad
blowout from it in the next few years
you know all the results because there's
going to be representatives that we're
not going to get
school that we don't get here all
because you know all these
tens of thousands of people who are not
counted right right right
all right jen um thank you thank you for
letting us know what's going on i wish
you had better news
yeah thank you david you have a great
day all right you too take care there's
a
jen from the epicenter of the border
between massachusetts and rhode island